[Música]
mientras el guerrero dormía una
serpiente se enroscó alrededor de su
rostro pero su esposa no la consideró
una amenaza sino un presagio un temible
poder conduciría a su esposo a la gloria
o a la perdición sin embargo por el
momento él era un esclavo uno entre
millones capturados en los territorios
conquistados por Roma para trabajar en
las minas labrar los campos o luchar
para entretener a la muchedumbre nacido
en tracia actual Bulgaria había servido
en el ejército Romano pero fue
encarcelado por desertar su nombre era
Espartaco
Espartaco fue trasladado a capua por
batiato un lanista o formador de
gladiadores y la vida en el urus la
escuela de gladiadores era inclemente
todo nuevo recluta debía hacer un
juramento ser quemado encadenado
golpeado y muerto a hierro y obedecer la
voluntad del amo sin cuestionar pero ni
esta disciplina férrea pudo el espíritu
de Espartaco en el año 73 antes de
Cristo Espartaco y otros 73 esclavos
robaron cuchillos y espetones de la
cocina y lucharon para escapar en el
camino interceptaron un carro cargado
con armamento de gladiadores ya no
pelearían por otros ahora luchaban por
su libertad cuando la noticia llegó a
Roma el senado estaba muy ocupado con
guerras en España y en el Reino del
ponto como para preocuparse por unos
esclavos revoltosos despreocupado cayó
Claudio glabro llevó un ejército de tres
mil hombres al monte vesubio donde se
refugiaban los Rebeldes y bloqueo el
único pasaje a la montaña restaba
únicamente esperar a que se rindieran
debido al hambre o eso fue lo que pensó
en medio de la noche Los Rebeldes
descendieron del monte con sogas hechas
de lianas y atacaron el campamento
desprotegido de glabro
así nació la leyenda del Gladiador
Rebelde de Roma
a medida que la rebelión se hizo más
conocida sus filas aumentaron con
esclavos prófugos desertores y
campesinos hambrientos muchos carecían
de entrenamiento pero las ingeniosas
tácticas de Espartaco los convirtieron
en una verdadera guerrilla una segunda
expedición romana liderada por publio
bariño fue emboscada cuando los
oficiales se bañaban para evadir las
fuerzas romanas restantes Los Rebeldes
usaron los cadáveres de sus enemigos
como disfraz y hasta robaron el caballo
de bariño para escapar
gracias a sus victorias y a su política
de distribuir los botines
equitativamente Espartaco continuó
trayendo adeptos y ganó el control de
aldeas donde podían forjarse nuevas
armas los romanos comprendieron entonces
que no se estaban enfrentando a unos
simples Fugitivos en la primavera del 72
antes de Cristo el senado respondió
enviando dos legiones completas Los
Rebeldes resultaron victoriosos pero
muchas vidas se perdieron en la batalla
incluso la del Teniente de Espartaco
en su honor Espartaco ordenó que se
llevaran a cabo juegos fúnebres en los
que sus prisioneros romanos debían
luchar como si fueran gladiadores
así el final del año 72 antes de Cristo
el ejército de Espartaco era una fuerza
de unos 120.000 soldados pero semejante
números resultó difícil de controlar con
el paso hacia los alpes despejado
Espartaco pretendía marchar fuera de las
fronteras de Roma donde sus seguidores
serían pero su ejército se había vuelto
Temerario muchos querían seguir
saqueando otros tenían la ambición de
marchar sobre la mismísima Roma
finalmente el ejército Rebelde se
dirigió al sur renunciando así a su
última oportunidad de ser libres
Mientras tanto Marcos lisinio craso
había tomado el mando de las fuerzas
romanas como era el ciudadano más
opulento de Roma persiguió a Espartaco
con ocho nuevas legiones y finalmente
arrinconó a los Rebeldes en la punta de
la bota de Italia tras intentos fallidos
de construir Balsas y luego de ser
traicionados por piratas locales Los
Rebeldes intentaron sin éxito romper las
filas de crasso los refuerzos de Roma
regresaban de Las Guerras mi tridácticas
y tanto las filas como el espíritu de
los Rebeldes se habían quebrado en el 71
antes de Cristo Los Rebeldes presentaron
su última resistencia cuando estaba a
punto de alcanzar a craso Espartaco fue
reducido por centuriones su ejército fue
destruido y seis mil prisioneros fueron
crucificados a lo largo de la vía apia
como muestra inquietante de la autoridad
romana
crazo ganó la guerra pero no es su
legado el que resuena en la historia
miles de años después el nombre del
esclavo que hizo temblar al imperio más
poderoso del mundo se ha convertido en
un símbolo de libertad y del coraje de
la lucha por ella
[Música]
otra figura de la historia que se abrió
su propio camino fue Sor Juana Inés de
la Cruz en este video descubra su
historia y por qué la Iglesia Católica
censuró sus escritos
[Música]